found an amazing series of old blog
posts as far as we can tell have
received basically no media attention
the person who wrote wrote them looks in
retrospect like a prophet calling for
America first policies at least a decade
before Donald Trump and her politics in
the days after Hurricane Katrina for
example the blogger in question
suggested that native-born Americans not
quote low-paid Mexican workers ought to
rebuild the city of New Orleans in 2006
the blogger said this about her
television viewing habits quote I love
Lou Dobbs his show has become required
viewing around my house the bloggers
largely agreed with Lou Dobbs on
immigration quote flying the Mexican
flag on US soil strikes me as incredibly
presumptuous and insulting to the US the
blogger went on to argue that illegal
immigrants to this country are not
coming here because they embrace our
ideals
they're coming for money which they then
send back to Mexico and she made a
pretty clear headed evidence-based case
for that in a 2005 post the same blogger
attacked Democrat Howard Dean for using
racist anti white rhetoric in a speech
quote tagging the other side the
Republicans as the party of whitey may
sound just like the way to get these
minority voters back but it so misses
the point the blogger later scolded
Howard Dean for insulting Christians and
white Americans who wrote all that we
could give you time to guess but she'd
never guess believe it or not it seems
like the author of what I just read was
joy read the now totally dogmatic
race-baiting MSNBC Weekend host
according to the Internet Archive so I
read apparently posted those views on
her now-defunct blog more than a decade
ago she wouldn't do that now MSNBC would
fire her right away for the crime of
independent thinking we repeatedly
contact to Jared's lawyer and MSNBC
today for comment and no one responded
to us it's possible that Reid will claim
those posts were written by a mysterious
hacker she's claimed that before the
last time she got caught with
embarrassing blog posts maybe she'll
blame the entire thing on Vladimir Putin
himself or some nameless Macedonian
agent or maybe she'll do the unexpected
and admit that there was a time before
the revolution currently in progress
when she was actually kind of smart and
reasonable we await her explanation